[Music]
joshua's in seattle hi joshua welcome to
the show
hey there how y'all doing better than we
deserve sir what's up
so i am a 30 year old single dad um just
got divorced earlier this year and
i am in about 38 000 worth of debt of my
own
i feel like i'm living paycheck to
paycheck and i
don't know where to start to just get
out of this
i've reached an emotional point where
i'm done i've had enough
i know i need to set up a budget but i'm
not sure how or anything like that or
what the first step would be
i'm so sorry about your situation josh
how long ago was the divorce when was it
finalized um it was finalized in january
okay
and coming out of this what kind of debt
is that 38 000
um so it is
personal loans i took out a while ago
and credit card debt okay
what's your income
65 000. okay what do you do for work
i'm a plumber
cool
how old are the kids
six and three
your full-time custody
i have 50 custody
okay
well we can definitely help you and
we'll give you some resources as well to
uh with this process number one getting
on a budget you're right that is the key
and it's a difficult thing to do and
part of this you might need to deal with
the kind of the trauma and the emotional
side to just get you know you got the
wind knocked out of you and so part of
it is just getting back up and going how
am i going to move forward with this new
life and what does this look like uh and
once we do that then we can focus on the
finances but it feels like you're just
treading water
are you able to cover your bills every
month put food on the table
i'm able to cover my bills every month
i can somewhat put food on the table
i've got friends and an adopted family
around that they help me out quite a bit
with making sure that i'm fed
and the kids are fed
that's good that's what we want you to
cover first everything else can wait and
if that means talking to the creditors
the credit card companies the lenders
and saying hey here's my situation
here's what i can do right now that's
okay how much do you owe in your car
um i own my car outright how much is
your rent
um so i actually have a mortgage and it
comes out to 2000 a month
and your take-home pay is what
so my take-home pay is
right around 4 500 a month but then i
also get um disability from the navy
and that comes out to 1500 a month
okay so you're bringing home 6 000
yeah
right right at it your house payment's
awful high bud uh it's thirty three
percent of your time you don't pay and
um
that's left over from the divorce
yeah that wasn't what you signed up for
that's left over from the divorce but
that's part of what's tanking your
monthly budget so yeah getting on a
written plan will make you feel like
you've gotten a raise getting on the
budget
and uh right so that's gonna be very
important but if we take your six
thousand dollars put at the top of the
page
and uh we take food out first and we
take lights and water out second and we
take house payment out third
your truck is paid for so you just got
to put gas and insurance on it that's it
and um
you know you've got some money here
you shouldn't be like begging food off
of friends
you're just disorganized you're just
disorganized and have the crap beat out
of you because it's been a hard year
but you've got mathematically you're
okay
you can you can work through this
um obviously you need to cut up the
credit cards and stop the borrowing you
can't you can't dig a you know you can't
dig your way out of a hole you gotta
you know you can't just keep get out of
a hole while you're digging out the
bottom you can't just keep digging so no
more debt chop them up get on a written
plan take care of food first lights and
water second house third then you've got
money left out of that
i mean there's
two three thousand bucks laying there to
do some stuff with and we can begin to
work on this and then the other thing
too is on the days you don't have the
kids i'd pick up extra time
as a plumber you can make some serious
money in overtime or side jobs one of
the two
right
and you know an extra thousand bucks a
month on this debt makes it go away a
lot
faster okay yep that's a short-term fix
but it's a short-term problem if we get
after it
so do you have any cash right now
anything in savings
i got about a hundred dollars
so step one we've got to get a buffer
between you and life and that's gonna be
a starter emergency fund of a thousand
dollars and we're gonna do get that as
quickly as possible we're talking a few
weeks here then we're gonna move on to
the debt snowball uh which is where we
pay off all the debt smallest to largest
regardless of the interest rate we're
going to walk you through this in
financial peace university that's going
to be our gift to you
nine videos in there also with that
every dollar that'll help you create
this budget income minus expenses should
equal zero a zero based budget every
dollar should have a job and you're
going to get to work and over the next
18 to 24 months you're gonna bust it to
get to a place where these kids see your
sacrifice and you can put food on the
table without having to worry about
anyone else yeah less than one month i
want a thousand dollars less than a
month later i went through these credit
cards gone
and so you're gonna list them smallest
largest you're gonna knock off the
little ones first and get some momentum
like george is talking about hang on
we'll get you signed up also get you
signed up for financial peace university
we'll get you into the class or where
you're learning how to handle money and
this all goes in your rear view mirror
then
and um this is the year of life change
for you so uh some of it bad some of it
good and we're here to walk with you so
hang on austin i'll pick up